these are the guts the question okay
very simple it says use the definition
of a parabola and the perpendicular
distance formula to find the locus of
points that is equidistant from here
thank you okay so here's what we're
going to think about this okay all and
they asked us to do something else in a
minute but we have to we have to get the
lockers first this is my variable point
right I'm gonna be the same distance at
this point as I am to this line so I'm
going to start off just by stating
geometrically what the definition of a
parabola is namely this distance to the
point the what's it called again I guess
is the same as the distance to this
point which is called that directory
sorry directrix I should have said line
okay so there you go there's my like
that's my geometric statement right look
I've got lengths of intervals here okay
and now if I go with my corner geometry
methods to actually evaluate this thing
okay so on the left hand side I just
have distance between two points I'm
gonna have what I'm gonna have a meet
the square root looks like an X plus 1
because there's a double negative plus y
take me one very good Oh square okay
then on the right hand side and then
they've actually included you into this
you neither perpendicular distance
formula coming in right because I'm
carrying a point to a line in order to
compare the point of the line I can't
use the line in its current form cannot
what do I have to do to do it
I needed in general form which is not
very difficult to do
excuse me beat it I have X and the
negative 2 on this side I'm just gonna
drag the Y over there X minus y -2 and
then just actually doesn't matter which
side it's on anyway okay you happy with
that so this general form now I can pop
it into the perpendicular distance for
okay it's just gonna be X minus y where
is 2 all over what the square root 2 I'm
just gonna write that as a squared plus
B squared damn it are you happy with
that now at this point just pause just
pause this already looks a little bit
different form though the main sort of
family of travelers that you're dealing
with because of this guy here you see
this what does this guy look like
this is a straight line clearly but it's
often an angle specifically because I
was a gradient for one it's often a
45-degree angle from the apples so it
looks like this okay there's the line
now
the lion's share parabolas that you'll
be dealing with are having a directrix
that's horizontal and sometimes you have
one that's vertical okay but this is
neither by the way negative 1 1 you've
got your focus up there right now in
order to we have a look at like just
visually what this would look like to
work out what the block is will be what
we have to do is get held in there right
it's clearly gonna pass through that
point that's midway between in fact
that's something that have to prove in a
second and then it's going to come away
like that that's weird but it's still a
problem it's just off at an angle okay
now because it's often an angle it's no
longer a function do you see that it
fails the UM it's failed the vertical
line test right if this had went further
around it's gonna whip up to around here
when you put your line here it's going
to intersect twice okay so it's not a
function that accounts for why when I
expand here right what do i do from this
thing like I've just stated the formulas
what do I have to do the both sides and
I'm gonna make it workable I've just
square both sides right so let's let's
do a couple of minutes yeah yeah perfect
square x squared plus 2x plus 1
another perfect square do it for each Y
square 2 y plus 1 okay on the right hand
side this right here we're not used to
having to deal with this guy over here
right we usually have because it's
usually a horizontal line we usually
have like what - 2 y + 1 or something
like that depending on its position and
when we square that it just ends up sort
of canceling with one of these guys
right like your Y squared disappears
which is why you have a y equals x
squared
normal happy parabola okay but here I
don't have them right when I squared
this out I'm just going to do it long
here I'm going to get this mess
okay so this is what makes this question
look a little bit if I don't write the
answers you have done it right remember
you're not going to get a function so
you should expect something that's a
little bit Messier wiki's don't deal
with the outer in exactly the same way
just don't be freaked out okay that's
the numerator what's on my denominator
it's a two because it's the square root
of two and I squared it okay now from
here like actually there's nothing hard
conceptually it's just that it looks
strange because of what you have over
there on the right hand side but I can
still work with it just the same I'm
gonna do two things on the left hand
side I noticed I've got two like terms
it's just the one in the one so they're
gonna become plus two but at the same
time excuse me I want to get rid of that
um didn't eliminate over there that's
just purse so I'll combine those like
terms and I'll multiply by two are you
happy with that does that leave me with
I'm gonna have 2x squared 4x I'm gonna
have 2 y squared minus 4y that was 2
when I added it and then it's going to
be 4 now that I told it you're happy
with that okay now this part over here
myself on this part over here I've
written along again just to make sure I
do the expansion right like you wouldn't
believe how many people will just expand
this incorrectly because it's got more
terms than you're used to like it's the
same thing you've got to go first term
times this one and then this one and
then this one and then you do the second
term times this one this one this one
how many terms will there be when I
finish it all up there will be three
times say which is known so let's just
quickly do this I'm gonna get X by X
which is x squared take away X Y take
away 2 X yep
now I'm going to do all the negative
wise watch out for the negative I'm
gonna have negative XY plus y squared
plus 2y
yeah and now it didn't last one which is
this negative two times all of those
guys again what's the negative negative
2x plus 2y plus okay first but it's fine
like it's just it's just a bit of
numerical muscle work right in fact
there's a whole bunch of things I think
it's
you write what kinds of things can I get
all okay I see a four here and a four
over there so Japan it's gone okay what
else do I see okay now just before I
before I start doing some of this right
I just generally generally speaking I
tend to go in order from because again a
lot of this and it's the same reason why
I expand because this is like you can
put this under category of exam
technique if you like there's nothing
wrong with doing this another way it's
just I've found this is less error-prone
I tend to go in order you just need some
order any order you like so long as it's
logical so that you don't end up missing
things my audit is to be from degree
okay so I look at the highest powers and
then I work my way down okay so for
instance I see square terms it's just
easy because I can count down quite
easily so I've got a 2x square - yeah
and I've got an x squared term over
there do you see that okay so if I lose
this one then I'll lose one over here
yeah okay again stay with degree I've
got to my spread over here and I've got
one over there so if I lose one here I
lose one there yeah that then I climb
down because I've got no more square
terms I've seen this 4x here and there's
takeaway for X here so things aren't
gonna cancel right I've got minus 4y yep
and then I have here it is plus 4y here
again things are not going to cancel
they're opposite signs right so in fact
I think you prepped me for wrong I think
I'm actually just eliminated all the
things that I just go straight cancel is
that all right and now I should just
combine them all on one side we were
part way through the way saying I've got
my x squared and my Y squared already
they just hanging out there for X you're
gonna add 4x to both sides so I'm gonna
get a it is you gonna take away full
wide you're gonna take away another or
white so I'm gonna have minus 8y yeah
and then what's left
add 2x wine both sides and that should
leave me with zero yeah
is there anything I can do that I could
I could complete the square on these
guys it's not that much point because
this guy's gonna be hanging out on the
side anyway which I should expect
because if I didn't have him there what
what is that
come on that's a circle right but this
is emphatic wait no listen
okay so in fact more or less that's it
there's not much detail you can do that
that is the equation that the lock is
okay like I said we are not used to the
presence of this guy or this guy but
it's because it's not a function which
we expected right from the get-go when
we did a very rough sketch okay that
make sense we're not quite finished one
more thing that they asked us to do they
say explain without referring and scuse
me
- its equation y each parabola passes
through the origin may give you -
promise that's why the page um now I
sort of drew it loofa scale but there it
is that's not what they refer to
they said the beginning used the
definition of a parabola and the
perpendicular distance formula okay
so how would I go about proving this
it's not complicated
now I can't I can't substitute in I
can't substitute into this right because
they said don't use the equation but
what I can use is the fact that if it's
on the Bacchus right it should obey this
right like that's where I started that's
not the equation of the Marcus that's
the definition okay so I'm going to take
advantage of this mat is zero zero if I
can find this distance and find this
distance what am I expecting they should
be the same I don't know that they're
equal yet so I can't use this in my
first line I'm just going to find out
what that is and then find out what this
is and they should be the same right the
only difference is I have a particular
point P in fact because the orange I'm
going to call it all right so I'm going
to say s or right what's the length
so this this is point here and I'm just
comparing to the origin like this is
super easy negative one take away zero
one takeaways here you okay with that
come on you can tell me that distance
okay and then I just could pin it to the
straight line which I'm gonna need
perpendicular this is form which is here
right but again that's really easy I'm
comparing from the distance revenue to
the directrix to the origin okay
perpendicular distance formula now here
it was X take away white take away -
what difference if I got here yeah zero
zero minus two divided by two this is
the absolute value of negative two which
is two divided by root 2 which sounds
like we're two to me so notice I did
each distance separately right so
therefore I can say s equals deeper
right which means that or satisfiers the
locus of the problem right therefore o
is on the front and the origin is part
of all the lockers cuz it satisfies the
geometric property I was interested in
okay